bella tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
nuovo video oggi tocchiamo una vetta mai
vista con il gioco che andiamo a fare ve
lo prometto azzarderei non tradire che
quasi come god simulator questo gioco
qua ha spopolato il sacco premi spazio
per starnazzare però non vedo l'ora
adesso la vedo eccola ciao bella che
voto contro per piegarsi in avanti very
good
that's trending premi tasto destro per
usare il becco ok a posso prendere le
robe
va bene che bello che deve essere
comunque fare l'oca nella vita c'è
veramente incredibile la mia ex
simulator si apre già arriviamo un punto
difficile del gioco porca vacca non si
apre la porta
facciamo le cose ti premuto s per
riunire è cosa per ridurre a ok
bellissimo sempre sognato di essere un
oca in questo in questo mondo giorno mi
scusi mi scusi i nomi picchi non mi
picchi sono solo sono solo un no che ho
fatto casino non volevo che comunque è
molto più gentile ed educata di come lo
ero io al parco quando avevo tre anni
juan tab per vedere cosa da fare di
comandi ok cose da fare ci sono perché
ovviamente le nel taccuino dell'oca
vediamo se riesco a fare entrare nel
giardino a posto ora devo bagnare
giardiniere mi scusi
sono io
e vabbè un clacson da sbrigare
madonna come fanno vedere ma si ceco ha
sì effettivamente non ha gli occhi
amistà solo allontanando ok non è tipo
come rombo simulator che mi seguono no
io quindi fosse romperti le balle
guardi voglio rastrellare con lei mi
scusi non c'ha voglia di rastrellare con
me che cosa dire guardi che l'ho rubato
un fiore guardi qua scudo veche andato
bene ho perso è visto che ho preso un
fiore vieni qua a yamada ripreso porca
vacca scaltro questo giardiniere scaltro
le zucche prendi una zucca premi una
zucca porca vacca le chiavi prese le
chiavi cori trovare le chiavi e non sono
via via via via via via via via via via
ga veloce nell'agone lago veloce a
bagnare già di yeah perché è entrato
nell'albo non entrato nel lago aiuto e
il tratto del lago non vale sta che sta
citando sono cit questi se ti riesce a
trascinare difficilissimo perché c'è il
tipo mi prende praticamente subito
quindi veramente difficile come può
stare attento che non mi veda forse di
fotografare lo butto nel lago
teoricamente non mi ha visto non mi ha
visto perfetto cielo ha apposto
meravigliosa oca che sono ben e prima
ancora voglio vedere se le chiavi del
giardiniere hanno un senso quindi fa
bene rubare di nuovo per favore averi
che sta lì che sta cercando rastrello
oddio ho fatto una cosa che non vuole mi
scusi guardi qua porca vacca ma non me
frega niente nel vaso voglio le chiavi
io ecco le prese corri
corri corri corri corri
no no aiuto devono arrivare alla con
l'alcol lago arriva c corri porca vacca
il lago era troppo lontano non ci sono
arrivato io sono arrivato perfetto corri
corri corri corri fregatene del
giardiniere fregate vai vai vai vai vai
e uno stealth game tipo metal gear
questo non ti deve vedere nasconditi
mettiti dentro cespuglio
ma mi sa che non ci arriva fino ai
ragazzi teoricamente cela dovrei aver
fatta il giardiniere senza chiavi sono
soddisfatto andiamo ad aprire la porta
eccoci qua chiavi dentro lucchetto però
non so come sia preferiamo che qualcosa
dovrà aprire per forza
mi scusi mi fatti aprire la porta c'ho
le chiavi porca vacca di sempre dove in
fila avesse chiavi perché c'è un modo
sicuramente servono ma non ho capito
cosa che non so sicuramente l'abilità di
girare la chiave però va bene allora
lasciamo le chiavi la e andiamo sul
prossimo obiettivo è fare un picnic
portiamo le robe alla coperta da picnic
perfetto non ho capito perché devo fare
un picnic in mezzo al prato
se sono un oca c'è posso mangiare
volendo qualsiasi cosa non mancano zucca
carota marmellata termo sera a dio tutto
sto casino a due le trovo avena carota
l'ho trovata tutta giardiniere
stoffregen ovvero giardiniere alla zucca
la mente è la carota lamentiamo qua
intanto poi vado a prendere la zucca
giocano nei paraggi in approfitto cosa
sta facendo
mi sembra di giocare e lo neighbor ogni
volta che arrivo ci qua sta facendo
qualcosa di strano qualcuno gli ha
rubato la carota e non capisce chi è
stato né è cresciuta un'altra e magico
questo comunque
la marmellata e questa manca il thermos
che sta lei la radio che non ho capito
dove dovrei trovare una radio va beh
ahia ahia ma visto ma visto corri corri
non son riuscito a fregarlo torri dai se
ancora vai corri di far vedere che lei
portai che te la porti libro che sono
petali e piglia cacasotto a posto il
caricamento dei sebadoh anomica è
entrato nel lago temerario questo qua o
a vedere se qualcosa ma eccola eccola
l'ho trovata ho trovato la radio occhio
aiuto
la radio il tutto nell'arco ha avuto
buttati nell'altro è vecchio questo
motore la radio nell'acqua teoricamente
dovrebbe esplodere prova niente perfetto
mamma mia come mi ascolto radio number
one
ci siamo perfetto abbiamo tutto let's go
fare un picnic c'è praticamente dovrei
mangiare mele le cose un nuovo elemento
delle cose da fare va bè farsi a non far
sì che giardiniere si dia il martello
sul pollice come faccio
non sono mica un mago ho visto dove il
martello ma come fa da solo sul pollice
eccolo non sta andando a prendere ha
preso hanno messo un cartello ok niente
ma come è ovvio che prova a togliere
rastrello mentre prendi mentre ti dà la
martellata per distrarlo aspetta dove
lista non fare in qualche modo poi di
nuovo la roba qua
ma porca vacca ci ho provato ma forse
starnazzando può essere perché ci prova
se viene dato subito fortissimo grazie è
svenuto forse è ok a posto grazie mi ha
aperto la porta togliti che vado avanti
grazie
e stato bellissimo sono proprio contenta
salve avevamo un mondo da scoprire
questo bellissimo allo ragazzi tra le
cose da fare o rompere la scopa immagino
sia questa chiudere il ragazzo nella
cabina far sì che il ragazzo si mette
gli occhiali sbagliati far sì che
qualcuno ricomprendesse cosa andare in
andare in televisione
vabbè poi mettere la cesta vai a fare la
spesa alla barella facciamo per l'ultima
che non c'ho voglia però intanto
scollega la corrente linea fresca di
strà della zia cosa non semplice
ecco ok non va neanche la cedaw lo va a
rompere le balle ammette aiuto ma volevo
andare dall'altra parte io c'è un
momento in cui posso prenderla scopo in
modo che lei non se ne accorga tipo
adesso come la rompo la scopa
aiuto aiuto è uscita è uscita è uscito
ai a molla la rotta la lotta alla rotta
tranquilla tela vado a buttare io lavata
butta aiuto aiuto è infatti cavoli tuoi
manco fosse tuo a maggia mai e allora
sai che faccio io più e io questo forza
via pia tanto che te ne fai è rotto
vabbè dai fa niente cavoli tuoi anzi ti
ruba anche un po di cartelli ma tanto
cos'è una specie di di carrefour però in
tutto questo vorrei vorrei capire come
si fa ad andare in televisione c'è
qualcuno che sta riprendendo
io posso entrare con la testa dentro una
televisione ave diciamoci sulle
televisioni quali vorrei capire come si
apre questa porta mi scusi forse ho
capito sai come faccio non so se si può
fare però proviamoci allora dell'isola
bisogna ricordarsi sempre che io sono
cosa fai
bisogna sempre ricordarsi che sono un
oca ma sono bella sveglia quindi devo
fare cose che le oche i normali non
possono fare tipo parlare con il walkie
talkie
se io prendo voi keytar chi glie lo
metto davanti alla porta e poi starnazzo
sull'altro teoricamente potrebbe
distrarre il tizio far uscire
teoricamente non è sicuro è perfetto
ora se io star nato su questo
eccolo è andato ad aprile
sto fregato
bellissimo adesso vai a metter la testa
nel perfetto
ok televisione perfetto aiuto va
cacciato e stato bellissimo sono stato
geniale veri che come oca o un futuro
come youtuber non lo so i ragazzi questo
è il primo episodio di untitled goodgame
si chiamerà simulator però secondo me
tra questo ed ex training proprio poi
fate voi ho io veramente un ritrovo vi
sia piaciuto ragazzi lo stesso racconto
mi piace iscrivetevi al canale e
schiacciata campanella che rimane da
giorni dizione video che escono e noi
come sempre ci vediamo al prossimo video
bene ragazzi
[Musica]